so let's think about this as an example
I'm going to give you some numbers and
the numbers don't come from thin air
they actually come from the syllabus
from an example that the syllabus wants
you to know it's going to consider what
if you were looking at this as kind of
like going forward in time as if you
were just pumping air in not just
actually putting Breton and you were
increasing that volume over time yeah
what I could say then is if I'm
increasing volume as time progresses I'm
not gonna have dy and DX one of the
things that's changing will be V for
volume that means how is the volume
changing and what I want to compare it
to is how time is changing yeah
now DV and DT I've arranged them like
this this over this because I want to
compare these two I'm not going to put
you have to write this down I'm not
gonna put DT on DV because if you were
explaining how something was changing
over time like say how fast the car was
driving over as time progressed
what kind of units would you use your
like my car is traveling at what speed
how would you describe its speed what
units would use kilometers per hour
meters per second that's kind of thing
now listen carefully to what you just
said right
you said kilometers per hour your time
you was at the end
you said meters per second the time
units at the end it's like this right
meters per second kilometers per hour
now that per is tewevision
right so the seconds the hours they
belong on the bottom there the second
thing that you're comparing okay now I'm
gonna give you a number here and again
like I said it comes from the syllabus
let's imagine if instead of you putting
you know one breath two breaths three
baths you can actually just blow into
the balloon at a constant rate and the
constant rate that this syllabus example
was giving to you is me millimeters
cubed per I'm pretty sure it's minute
let me just double check cuz I'm ready
time over here
well no it's seconds of course because
millimeters kids are really small sorry
okay so just a little side note here
I've put this off on the side to
indicate to myself hey this these are
the units that this thing is dealing
with okay I haven't attached it to here
because you would say the volume is and
number and then you're attached the
units on the side so the derivative
itself has no units just like an
integral you know when I when we were
doing area and volume you'd work out the
integral and you get a number at the end
and that thing you don't attach units to
it okay now if that's how volume is
changing tell me some other things that
were changing as you blew air into your
balloon give me another value that's
changing radius so I could consider how
the radius is changing over time that
works what else is changing about the
blue you see anything else that is
increasing or decreasing yeah my my
balloon is clearly a little bit it's got
a bit of an identity problem here okay
apart from things that are limitations
to me not having use the same balloon
over and over again what else do you
notice that say getting bigger surface
area is getting bigger okay so these are
things that we can all try and work out
from this situation okay now here's my
question for you let me just rub off
this stuff that's irrelevant if I know
if I state to you that the rate of
change of the volume is this how do I
get from that to these things what am I
going to need to do here hmm I need to
connect the information that I've got
with this information that I don't have
through well how are volume and radius
connected together what what knowledge
do you have that connects the volume of
a sphere to its radius I think you know
an equation don't you if we just think
about volume and radius first will come
to area in a second what would you say
we're on color what would you say that
volume equals to in will in terms of the
in terms of the radius
think we did this acting like you sell
net right 4/3 PI R cubed very good now
this tells you sorry it's a really bad
fall let's fix that it's a bit better
this tells you a relationship between
volume and radius that you can use to
bridge this gap you can use to bridge
this gap I want you to think about two
one wheeler chain rule right when we
learnt chain rule we used it with Y and
X and we introduced a new letter like
you for example okay but we don't need
to introduce any new letters here all
the letters are there right have a look
have a think I want to have D are on
something times something on DT that'll
get the dr and their DT in the right
spots are you okay with that that makes
sense so what if you have a look at all
the information that I have here what is
a good candidate for going into these
two spots DV it's the only other piece
of admission I really have anything
about right I could put DV here and I
know exactly what that's equal to I
could put DV here and I don't know what
this is equal to but I can find out have
a look at what we said was the
relationship between volume and radius
what can I do to get to that I can
differentiate now because we've got all
of these extra variables flying around
you can't just say I'm gonna find the
derivative because there's lots of
derivatives I have already written one
two three I'm about to write no note
four on the board right so what am I
going to differentiate with respect to
what variable would make sense if I'm
starting from here it's our isn't it
this equation is all about ah
so I'm going to differentiate with
respect to R is that okay what is the
derivative you can do the rules from
here for the 3s are going to cancel PI R
and the power reduces by one you can
that now DV on dr is that the thing that
I want it's not is it it's actually the
it's the reciprocal of what I want right
so part of me we're going to come back
to this guy in a second when I need this
space briefly instead of writing in that
in place of dr DV I'm gonna put in its
reciprocal that's one on 4 PI R squared
care with that you see how I've used
that factor of differentiation in here
what's DVM DT again it's just the number
yeah it's a constant yeah so now I can
tidy this up just a little bit I guess
I'd write 35 on 2 pi squared okay how's
your brain so far does that make sense
what have we done here we've taken a
piece of information that we knew about
how quickly air was going in and then we
used where we use some geometry right
then we use some calculus then we use
some more calculus and now we've got a
new rate of change okay